we are at the very tail
end
of
the parts
of which is really a more
expansive chapter
of authored
by we were discussing
his physical descriptions his
physical traits the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam and we reach to the very end
just a few more sentences left in that
chapter after which we will
move to the chapter regarding his
miracles
[Silence]
tells us where we left off last
week with regards to the description of
the Prophet sallallahu alam's cloth
clothing what he would most prefer to
wear with regards to color and with
regards to style of
clothing he
says he the most preferred type of
clothing that he would wear was
Al
is what we refer to commonly as a
thob and
this is something
that is a very long shirt it's
exactly what I'm wearing here this
is very similar to the cut of
a and he preferred white
clothing is that which is pin stripes he
liked pin stripes in his clothing this
was most predominant ly made in
Yemen he tells us
that often the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam length of sleeves would usually
be to his
wrist
likewise on occasion the prophet
s would wear
a which is kind of a a Long
Jacket is a loin cloth and this is what
was most commonly worn in the time of
the prophet sallallah wasam a loin cloth
is the lower part of what we wear
what men wear in
in it's wrapped around and tied at the
waist
likewise is the part that goes over the
over the
shoulders and on
occasion he would wear two pieces of
green and he liked the color
green and on occasion he had worn a Juba
which is a
long
a long
cloak but the sleeves of this jell were
particularly tight and narrow
and so when he would make W when he wore
this particular jba he would usually
lift it and to get his hand out rather
than lift the sleeve all the way
[Silence]
up
tells us that on occasion the prophet
sallam was narrated to have worn a black
turban and usually he would
leave or he would bring the ends of
the turban out to the back and they
would hang between his shoulder
blades but this isn't his most common
color of turban most common color was
white as we mentioned before
but he tells us
here meaning on occasion it has been
narrated
seldom that he wore a black turban it's
been narrated that he
did
likewise
has been narrated to have
worn of different types of cloth so
he's worn
cotton likewise
wool
likewise that which is made of sh sh is
the
the skin the hide the hair of goats
goat
hair likewise he did wear a
ring
and this is an
issue that the scholars debate is it
considered the
Sunnah for a person for a man to wear a
ring what's apparent is that the prophet
s.
wasam began to wear a
ring
constantly after his migration to
Medina when he migrated to Medina and he
started
to be in a role of
governance and he had a seal a seal was
on his ring that he would you know
place his his seal on different letters
that would be sent out
to to his platoon leaders to his
generals
to other Statesmen
Etc and so
usually a king or a leader or a judge or
anyone who had a seal would usually wear
it as a ring so that it could not
be stolen or that his seal or signature
if you will
be forged so that you know no forgeries
would come out in his name and so he
began to wear this ring it was first of
gold after this this was
abated and it became Haram for men to
wear gold and only for women to wear
gold
and so then he had this ring made out of
silver and he wore it
s
now the most correct way to view this is
that if a
person has a
seal or something that
is denoting Rank and wears a ring in
that regard then this would be the
Sunnah otherwise
otherwise it is merely mu it is
permissible for a man to wear a ring of
silver it's never been narrated that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
authentically wore any
jewelry other than a
ring
likewise it has never been narrated
authentically that he wore any jewelry
made of any precious metal
other than gold and silver gold at the
beginning in the early days of Islam
after this it was abated as is
in and so all of the companions the men
they stopped wearing gold and they
started to wear
silver as
for you know bracelets necklaces
things that these are not things
that he was ever narrated to have
worn likewise a lot of us we get
our we
get incorrect F wrong Impressions
about how people dressed and spoke and
behaved in the time of the prophet
sallallah alaih wasallam and we imagine
things that are incorrect for
instance
because
of certain television
shows certain series that were made in
the Arab world in the last 10 20 years
some of them depicting the
companions some of them depicting some
of the greater names of Islam and
the greater characters of
Islam
in these television shows in these
movies men are often depicted to dress a
certain
way or to have or Adorn themselves with
certain jewelry like
earrings it's actually a common
misconception amongst many
people that men wore earrings in the
time of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam this is not narrated anywhere
this is something that was specific to
women in the time of the Prophet s.
wasam and not even all women just
usually women that were from more
prestigious backgrounds who would
have money or resources to pierce their
ears men did not wear
earrings and you know some of these
shows they have like
even some of the mushin the
polytheists the non-muslims or even some
of the Muslims on occasion and the Rings
or the earrings they would be wearing
these very long earrings or these
big hoop in one ear a pirate or
something and none of this is correct
this is a common
misconception these are not things that
were traits of the Arabs at that time
in the way that they
dressed likewise he wore Al Al
is also misunderstood amongst a lot of
Muslims is a kind of sock it's a
footwear that's made out of hard
tanned leather now notice the words that
I chose there hard
tanned
leather when we often think about
leather socks is referred to as leather
socks some
people or in
some it is only permissible to wipe over
your Footwear if you are wearing leather
socks but not on Cotton for
instance and so many people buy
purchase go out looking for leather
socks so that they can wipe over their
socks especially in the
winter and the problem here is a
misconception and a misunderstanding of
what a is in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam a leather
sock would be worn in place of
shoes they're not worn together a person
would not wear a hoof and then wear a
Nile on top of it leather socks are hard
tanned leather that when you they when
you set it up it stands up on its own
a pair of boots that's how it would
look the soles of this leather sock
would be very
hard and
and
so these leather
socks that would be
worn in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the
narrations in bukari and Muslim and many
of books of
narration that
discuss leather socks H and is
translated as leather
socks in our time because these things
don't really exist in our area they
don't it's not really something that's
worn
anymore we have shoes now that have
soles we can't really imagine wearing
socks without
shoes we begin to
misunderstand and we begin to
extrapolate
our our culture and our clothing and our
dress and superimpose it on to the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam time
this is important why is it important
it's important for us when we read about
any of the descriptions of the Prophet
sallam any of the descriptions of
clothing or anything that that we
understand it properly correctly this
it's been you know 1500 years and
clothing has changed a lot since that
time very rarely will we find clothing
that is I identical or even in many
cases close to that of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
time our clothing is pretty much usually
mass-produced it is
designed to work within the ecosystem of
our environment our environment is one
that is very soft very easy it is not
the environment
of the desert the heat the sand the
ruggedness of that time know for
instance person goes and buys a pair of
shoes most of us probably have I don't
know 10 15 pairs of shoes most people in
our
in our time and place this is the
norm and then people wear different
shoes every day you know whatever their
outfit is or or whatever but if a person
were to wear the same shoes every single
day they wouldn't last 2 three months
because they're made cheaply and they're
made just to get from the house into the
car and from the car into the house
maybe walk up the sidewalk for a block
or two and that's the most walking we do
we're walking around in the mall you
know we don't even walk through the
grass in our Footwear our shoes our
clothing couldn't be more different
than that of the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when you read
that the prophet sallallah alai wasallam
had
two when you read that he had two or
three cloaks that's it that's all he
had he had one for special occasions and
one that he wore all the time that's it
just one or just two or some of them
would would only have one one outfit
that they had to wear and when they were
washing it they're naked they would take
it off in pieces to wash it right but
those things were handmade they were
made durability person could wear them
and walk through the desert and these
things would would be able to
tolerate that kind of abuse and that
kind of strenuous environment
our clothing not so much if a person
wore the same shirt every day about a
week week and a half it'll start falling
apart because they're really just not
made for that even if washing washing
your clothes too much will make it fall
apart I mean they're made to kind of
disintegrate as we wear them
very
cheap made mass produced anyways this is
the environment that we have chosen as
Humanity to live in right now but this
is a very different environment than the
time of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam if we want to
discuss something of how he
dressed how things were especially if
it has to do with a ruling of Islam like
for instance the
H
right so in in in many and the and other
others it's not permissible to wipe
over anything less than a leather
sock
right and
so in certain mids and certain
communities is a very serious thing for
them there was an occasion where I
went to a mid in in New York
City and it was a there's a group of
very extreme Brothers
there that
were practitioners of the
Han and it was Winter I had a pair of
socks on I was making W I was just
stopping off in the Masid to pray and
leave
and as I'm making
wo this brother comes in and starts
yelling at me I mean really just yelling
at me and telling me you can't wipe over
your cotton socks they're made out of
cotton and all the and you don't have
and you're not even making and just goes
on and on about this
whole and so in trying to discuss this
with him he just he didn't want to hear
it but it was so bad that when I tried
to to stand in the row to make Sal they
actually took me physically out of the
row and put me all the way at the end in
the back so that I'm not in the row
because in their mind I'm praying
without wo if I'm praying without wo I
shouldn't be praying in the row I'm
going to break the
ranks ordering on Insanity
so the idea was all of them were wearing
these leather
socks
understanding the H to be a leather sock
in our culture when we say the word
socks socks are worn alone or are they
part of are they part
of are they worn on their own or do we
wear them with something we wear socks
with shoes we don't have in our culture
any type of socks that are worn
alone
right whether they're leather or
otherwise we have shoes we have sandals
we have socks socks go with shoes
right and so in their mind when they
read the word
Hof and it's translated then into
English as leather
socks what comes to mind a soft leather
that I can wear with
shoes and so we start making these
leather
socks and we start to think that these
are the Sunnah this is what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam wore and this
is a gross misunderstanding of
What Not only the narrations but also a
gross misunderstanding of of the of the
knowed Malik yes they spoke
about but they also went into great
detail even in their
time discussing what exactly are the
parameters of
a what is
a so some of them say you have to be
able to walk at least a half mile
without it falling apart some of them
say when you stand it up it stands up on
on its own some of them say you have to
be able to walk at least 9 miles Etc
they have different parameters that they
mention because clothing changed even in
those 200 years after the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam
passing the point here that we're making
is we do not ever want to base Islamic
rulings on translation
of Islamic texts from Arabic to English
right it's it's already as difficult
difficult enough to properly understand
the context of the Quran and Sunnah in
Arabic let alone let it be translated
and then try to derive rulings from
those translations this is the position
of scholarship is what Scholars are for
we take what they say and we follow that
in obedience to Allah subhanahu waala
unless it's known to be a mistake of a
particular scholar that's it this is our
position
as the general masses of the
Muslims
so again this is not a leather sock it's
a Footwear in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaih
wasallam that would take the place of
shoes a person is either wearing a h or
he's wearing a a shoes he's not wearing
these this hoof and then putting that
into his shoe it wasn't even possible
Right very hard leather tanned leather
that they would use to walk for miles
and miles and walk through the desert
and they would go to Wars and so forth
and these
things and it's also been
authentically narrated
that the
companions notably some of the wives
of the Prophet s. wasam and
also sons of the companions such as
abdah abdah
ABB and
others that they would wear cotton socks
and they would wipe over these cotton
socks even though that's not what we're
discussing now just to clarify that
anyhow likewise the prophet s. wasam was
narrated to have worn shoes so he was
narrated to have
worn the leather Footwear he was also
narrated to have worn
shoes and shoes at that time were
usually made out of hide
right so I'm usually
using camel hair or something that
and were a little bit more durable and
they were usually used more for cold
in order to insulate the feet and act as
a better insulation and more warmer for
a person than
than just the thin thinner leather
leather
[Silence]
of we are now in the chapter we've gone
through the character the physical
characteristics of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam we've gone
through the character of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam now we are
going through some of his miracles that
he performed during his lifetime
there's a few
introductory things that we have to kind
of understand before we get in get into
this chapter
the first thing is
that miracles of the Prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam are of two
main types there are those which are
Miracles with regards to
information or
meanings and there are Miracles which
were physical physical Miracles
things that
things that otherwise should not be able
to happen would happen physically to the
physical world around
us
but if we try to go through all of the
Miracles of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that were narrated all
of them authentically and all of them
that were mentioned in the
Quran we would not be able to very
easily put a number on
them mentions that they
are in the
thousands
right and that's not just counting what
happened during his time but also what
happened after his time
why
because in the any Miracles that
happened with the
companions let's say some one of the
companions has something miraculous
happened to him or someone who's not
Muslim sees something miraculous in the
absence of the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam and
then comes to find out or is led to
Islam through this this is considered
the scholars consider this to be a
miracle of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam why because he is the purpose
the reason for this
happening
likewise Miracles that happened for
the
companions either during his lifetime or
after his passing these are also
considered of the Prophet Muhammad's
Miracles likewise any Miracles that
happen throughout the Muslim umah after
his time why because these miracles
happen as a result of f following the
prophet Sall alai wasam so they are
considered of his
miracles another thing
to
to understand this issue of
Miracles and that is that the
purpose of a
miracle in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Quran
and the Sunnah the main
purpose is to
affirm and
substantiate the prophet
Muhammad's claim to prophethood this is
the
point and so when a prophet comes to his
people he has Miracles that are
performed for him or that he is a
able to perform in order to prove the
validity of his prophethood he comes and
says I'm a prophet and otherwise there
wouldn't anyone could claim to be a
prophet but in order for people to
reasonably distinguish charlatans from
those who are genuinely Messengers or
prophets from Allah that these Miracles
are performed right and these miracles
do not are not in any
way
similar to the kind of
trickery or slight of hand
that soothsayers and wizards and
witches and stuff do this is very
different another thing about miracles
is
that these Miracles are performed by
Allah subhanahu
and it is not
necessarily it is not necessary if we
understand that the reason for the
miracle the purpose of the
miracle is to prove the
validity of his
prophethood any Miracle should suffi
suffice it doesn't have to be a miracle
on
request right
so for
instance many of the
disbelievers they would those who are
trying to bely the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would come to him and
demand that he do a very specific
thing right so we're living in the
desert make it into a
jungle let's see make the desert into a
jungle and put some rivers over here and
put another River over here right
this is not a request or a demand that
needs to be honored in the case of a
miracle
why because the whole point of a
miracle is not to change the nature of
the world for people to live in the
point of a miracle is to prove the
validity of a messenger's prophethood
that's it so anything that is beyond the
scope of possible physically possible
to the world as we know it to be will
suffice any of these things is good
enough
right as for performing a miracle based
on a demand or a request this is a
different
thing Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
may see
it appropriate
to
ask Allah subhanahu waala to honor a
particular request and be considered a
miracle or
not but this in no way takes away from
the
validity of his
prophethood because a person
who disbelieves after seeing the proof
after seeing the proof the
evidence of a messenger or a
prophet's
prophethood this person who in spite of
seeing these proofs these
evidences refuses to
believe they have already made their
mind up that they're not going to
believe doesn't matter what they see or
what they're
shown and so they will latch on and hang
on to any
argument to
reject the the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam message any
argument so for
instance if he were to do everything
they requested they would say well it's
you know you say you come from Allah but
it sounds to us you just do what
whatever we
say right we ask you for something and
you do it you must be a magician or
something not a messenger because a
messenger doesn't get to do what he
wants to Allah's
discretion so now it's you're honoring
our requests or our demands too
much or it would be the opposite right
we asked you to do this you didn't do it
therefore you're not a Prophet this is
this is a fruitless Endeavor to try to
satisfy the demands of someone who has
already
decided no matter what they see they're
not going to they're not going to
believe they're not going to
accept so the Miracles of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam are not by
demand or by request they are to the
discretion of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Allah subhanahu wa taala tells us this
in in the Quran very
clearly he says
[Silence]
subh so Allah subhah waala says they the
antagonists of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam they
say if only he could provide us with a
miracle to prove the validity of his
claims he's provided them with many
miracles but
they decided that those are not the
right Miracles that they want they want
specific Miracles so they would ask for
certain
things some of them asked for the day of
judgment to
commence seriously they came to him and
they said if you're truly a prophet make
the day of judgment happen
now and put us in hell this was their
request it's Insanity right and
so they claim that he did not provide
them with
Miracles and what they mean is Miracles
according to their discretion Allah
subhanahu wa tal said say to them that
the Miracles are to the discretion of my
Lord I I am just a Warner and one
bringing Glad Tidings for those who
believe this is not to my discretion
it's not something that I get to decide
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
doesn't decide the Miracles that he
performs anymore than he decides what
the Quran will say these are all to
Allah subhanahu waala and his discretion
he chooses What miracles to show What
miracles to refrain from
[Silence]
Etc
another thing to take into
consideration is that
in the later texts of Islamic
scholarship people began referring to
Miracles as
Miracles is translated to Miracle in the
earlier texts in the Quran in the Sunnah
Miracles are not really referred to with
that wording usually they're referred to
as signs or evidences right which is
what they
are
inshallah next week we will take a
deep dive into the specific miracles of
the
prophet